heute zum beispiel auch was die leute
doch wirklich interessiert zum beispiel
ganze corona geschichte wenn einer ein
fachmann sagt leute jetzt machen wir mal
so uns oder wir beenden das ding jetzt
einfach mal zu gast sein so will sie
kümmern wo man die leute abholt ich hab
doch nichts verstauen und sagt das war
einfach klasse nein nein kohler sichere
bei aber jetzt zum beispiel den leuten
immer mal diese angst nehmen dass es
nicht weitergehen kann auch man jetzt
wirklich da auch mal zu sagen es nervt
uns doch alle maske auf masken ein maske
ja hier kurz wieder da nein irgendwie
was darf ich denn macht doch einfach
eine ansage oder auch das ganze bitte
lassen sie sich impfen das holt doch
keinen mehr ab es ist doch ganz einfach
so wer sich nicht impfen lässt der lässt
sich einfach nicht impfen das ist ja
jedem sein gutes recht aber dann möchte
man auch keine tränen hören wenn auf
intensivstationen liegen sollte
irgendwas anderes da musst du halt
einfach auch wenn dubai hat mit chris
muss man sagt ja was ja nicht impfen
lassen pech ich gleich und verantworte
eigenverantwortung da macht jetzt halt
nicht und jeder muss für sich selber
doch jetzt auch entscheiden was er zum
beispiel macht in der korona zeit also
mich zum beispiel auch bei auftritten
was anderes war letzte woche das erste
mal wieder irgendwie weg in köln und so
was und wo man auch denkt so war lustig
ja es war es war mehr oder weniger
lustig ist es immer noch ein bisschen
befremdlich weil man ja auch diesen
massen ist aber es ist genauso unsinnig
wie diese ganzen bestimmung irgendwie
sondern wir sind ja gerade hergeflogen
vorher bitte warten sie reihe eins bis
fünf steigt aus damit du danach im bus
mit 80 leuten stößt das ist genau so ein
bullshit erhält die ganze zeit politisch
ja auch funktioniert und 1 wissen wir
doch einmal doch in den letzten 18
monaten gesehen dass wirklich jedes amt
nacheinander durchgegangen wurde und
komplett versagt hat damals ministerium
danke versagt was sollen wir hier
gesundheitsmesse danke niester so innere
sicherheit egal wo es war
außenministerium jeder hat es unisono
und da verdanken
[Musik]